before I die and I'm 77 I'm honest about
that I before I die what I want is that
the system changes Deanna Maher worked
in John Conyers Michigan office from
1997 to 2005 she started part-time and
rose to his deputy chief of staff Maher
says there were three instances of
sexual misconduct - that would be
considered sexual assault the first she
says happened in 1997 in a Washington
hotel room another staffer had booked
Conyers came in into the bedroom he
stripped his clothes off did he touch me
no but Maher says Conyers did touch her
during a car ride in the spring of 1998
he is feeling me up and I'm shoving his
hands off Ben in 1999 she says he
crossed the line again in front of
constituents in his home district he
stuck his hand up my dress and whispered
in my ear I didn't think you had great
legs before I didn't report it I knew
and everybody knows it would have gone
nowhere nowhere 88 year old Conyers the
longest-serving current member of
Congress denies any wrongdoing
Arnold Reed is his attorney these are
things that they're going she is going
to have to prove and explain that is
going to be her burden Maher says her
goal is clear as the saying goes I want
to clean the swamp